>>> THIS WEEK, PEACOCK DROPPED
THE TRAILER FOR "BEL AIR,"
EXECUTIVE PRODUCER WILL SMITH'S
MODERN, DRAMATIC REIMAGINING OF
THE "FRESH PRINCE" STORY
>> THIS TOWN WILL MAKE YOU
FORGET WHERE YOU CAME FROM
NOW WE'RE PROUD TO DEBUT THE
NEXT '90s SHOW
ABOUT THE BLACK EXPERIENCE TO BE
GIVEN A SERIOUS, HIGH-STAKES
REMAKE
>> CHICAGO
PEOPLE FROM OUTSIDE CALL IT
CHIRAQ, BUT I CALL IT HOME
AROUND HERE, AIN'T NO GOOD NEWS
ON THE NEWSPAPER'S PAGE.
ONLY ADVANTAGE I'VE GOT.
MY MIND.
THAT DON'T COUNT FOR MUCH IN
THESE STREETS BECAUSE OUT HERE,
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE YOUR OWN
NAME
FROM EXECUTIVE PRODUCER
JALIL WHITE AND KEVIN FINLEY,
WRITER OF THE "FAMILY MATTERS"
EPISODE.
EURKEL
ACCIDENTALLY SWITCHES BODIES
WITH THE PRESIDENT
>> THERE'S ONLY ONE GIRL FOR ME,
YO
>> WHO
LAURA WINSLOW?
THE BOUGIE NEIGHBOR GIRL
>> THE GOOFY CHARACTERS YOU
LOVED IN THE '90s WITH
ABSOLUTELY NONE OF THE FUN OR
CHARM.
>> FLOWERS, MY PET
>> PLEASE, IT AIN'T LIKE THAT
BETWEEN US
I'M NOT YOUR PET
>> I LOVE YOU.
>> STEVE, NOW GET THE HELL OUT
OF HERE!
♪
>> YOU WERE HARD ON THAT BOY,
DAD.
NO, LIFE NOT A BEEN EASY FOR
HIM.
FATHER'S GONE, MOTHER'S A DRUNK.
>> WHEN YOU GONNA STOP WORKING
ON
THIS STUPID ROBOT AND MAKE SOME
MONEY FOR THIS FAMILY?
>> WHAT FAMILY
>> I RAISED A DAMN NERD.
>> A YOUNG GENIUS ALONE IN THE
WORLD.
♪
>> YOU DON'T LOVE HER.
>> NO, BUT I LOVE HOW SHE MAKE
IT CLAP.
>> OH, MY NOSE
DID I DO THAT?
WHAT IF I SHOT YOU IN THE FACE
>> DROP THE GUN, STEVE
DID I DO THAT?
>> "ROLLING STONE" RAVES "FAMILY
>> DROP THE GUN, STEVE
MATTERS" IS THE NUMBER ONE WORST
>> "ROLLING STONE" RAVES "FAMILY
CHOICE FOR A SITCOM TO MODERNIZE
MATTERS" IS THE NUMBER ONE WORST
LIKE THIS, WHILE "ENTERTAINMENT
CHOICE FOR A SITCOM TO MODERNIZE
WEEKLY" ADDS THIS GIF OF
LIKE THIS, WHILE "ENTERTAINMENT
KEVIN HART BOOKING'S HORRIFIED
WEEKLY" ADDS THIS GIF OF
>> THE STEVE URKEL I KNOW IS WAY
KEVIN HART BOOKING'S HORRIFIED
TOO SMART FOR THAT NONSENSE.
>> THE STEVE URKEL I KNOW IS WAY
>> SMART DON'T MATTER IF YOU
TOO SMART FOR THAT NONSENSE.
DON'T HAVE ANY KEYS.
>> SMART DON'T MATTER IF YOU
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
DON'T HAVE ANY KEYS.
OUT HERE
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
SO, I'VE BEEN A CHICAGO COP FOR
OUT HERE
20 YEARS
SO, I'VE BEEN A CHICAGO COP FOR
WHERE'S THE GIRL
20 YEARS
>> GO TO HELL, PIG
WHERE'S THE GIRL
>> PIG
>> GO TO HELL, PIG
>> OH!
>> PIG
>> BITCH
>> OH!
>> IF YOU CONTINUE DOWN THIS
>> BITCH
PATH, YOU'RE GOING TO WIND UP
>> IF YOU CONTINUE DOWN THIS
DEAD OR LOCKED UP BY YOUR 18th
PATH, YOU'RE GOING TO WIND UP
BIRTHDAY
DEAD OR LOCKED UP BY YOUR 18th
>> AIN'T NOBODY GOING TO CARE.
BIRTHDAY
I AIN'T GOT A FAMILY.
>> AIN'T NOBODY GOING TO CARE.
>> YOU'RE WRONG, STEVE
I AIN'T GOT A FAMILY.
THE WINSLOWS ARE YOUR FAMILY